نحو البحر الاسود يركز الناتو انظاره
واهتمامه والعوامل الدافعه لهذا الاهتمام
كثيره صيام الامنيه والجيول السياسيه منها
لتتحول تلك البقعه المائيه الى بؤره توتر
لن تنتهي اليوم او غدا ونظرا لحيويه هذا
البحر كثرت غايات ونوايا الدول المطله
وغير المطله كالولايات المتحده حول
التواجد على سواحل ومنافذ البحر الذي سمي
بالاسود كنايه عن الغيوم والسحب السوداء
التي تتجمع فوقها هذا البحر وتنبع
استراتيجيه البحر الاسود بالنسبه
بقياده الولايات المتحده من قضيتين اولا
الالتزام بامن الحلفاء وفقه معاهده
الحلفاء اذ ان ثلاث دول اعضاء من اصل ست
تطل على البحر الاسود وهي تركيا وابو
الغاليه ورومانيا ثانيا تعتمد روسيا احد
اكبر الخصوم وسياسيين للولايات المتحده
على منطقه البحر الاسود في مجالات الطاقه
والتجاره والامن والاقتصاد ومن ثم لطالما
اعتبرت هيمنتها على منطقه البحر الاسود
مساله بقاء وطني وتستخدم روسيا ايضا
قواعدها في البحر الاسود التي يقع كثير
منها في شبه جزيره القرم لشمله عمليات
عسكريه ام بعد من اوكرانيا في سوريا مثلا
كما ان البحر الاسود يشكل اليوم ممرا هاما
وحيويا لشحن الحبوب من اوكرانيا الى
العالم وهو امر متعلق بالامن الغذائيه
العالميه ويتدفق الوقود من القوقاز واسيا
الوسطى الى اوروبا والعالم عبر البحر
الاسود ايضا وحوله اضافه الى رواسب
الهيدروكربونات الغنيه في البحر وعليه
مشاهدينا زادا من وجود قوته في المنطقه
منذ عام 2014 كما انها اي قوه تقوم
بدوريات روتينيه في المنطقه بطائرات
مراقبه متقدمه لكن هذا ليس كافيا وفقا
لخبراء عسكريين امريكيين فعلاناته ان يمد
رومانيا بصواريخ متطوره مضاده للسفن
والتفاوض مع الدول الواقعه على نهر
الدانوب بشان استخدام السفن الحربيه هناك
لتحقيق نوايا الحلف في البحر الاسود
[موسيقى]